Hey,
what's going on it's Bill Burr.
It's time for the Monday morning podcast for mon-.
day.
October 16th,
2070 what's going on?
How are you?
Oh,
freckles is in a good mood.
He is in a great mood.
What a,
what a fucking great win.
Gadee great.
When by the New England patriots.
Noncontroversial nothing to complain about.
I don't understand what the jets eco.
It was clearly,
hey,
did the guy look like a,
you ever see when people join the mafia and they got a hold that little candle
like he was doing that for one hand to another?
Clearly not a catch.
I mean,
oh he caught it and then it was a fumble.
I'm fucking with you.
Your Green Card.
I don't get it either.
That looked like a touchdown to me and you know what sucks.
I wish that they called it a touchdown cause then it would have been tied up and
I could have watched Tom Brady go right down the field and break your fucking
green hearts once again,
the fucking nerve or you jet fans to act like you got fucked out of a victory.
What you got fucked.
Would you know what you've got the end of the,
the refs gave you mercy.
They gave you some mercy.
Let's just put them out of their fucking misery.
C'Mon man,
the guy,
how many you fucking fair with the best.
It's because of that call.
We'll able to go down there and get to your fucking green and white.
Hi Yan Day.
Whatever the fuck it is you're driving right.
And left the stadium early because of that wonderful accurate call.
Um,
I'm fucking with you guys.
I'm just being a Douche.
I don't,
I don't get it either.
I,
I wish I was at Cole.
I wish it was called a touchdown.
They don't have been tied up.
Would've been exciting game music,
cited gay,
but you know,
add to the drama tie score.
Who's gonna win the jet,
who the Patriots have used as a fucking blow up doll for the last 15 years.
This sick of this sick allusion to the circle losing to these New England
patriots,
these patriots of the Lakeland.
Um,
this is what I love.
You know,
what was my favorite part of that game was when the jet scored the first
touchdown to go up seven enough.
And if you can look at the highlight,
look in the crowd,
that dude,
the jet fan with the,
he's got the Jersey on,
he's holding his smart phone and he's given double fingers at like one of the
New England patriots,
a defensive bad,
like,
fuck you.
I got to MIT as a sports fan.
I know what that feeling is like,
you know,
I haven't known it for a good 15 years,
16,
17 years.
But I,
I,
you know,
the first 32 years of my life,
34 years I'll,
you know,
depending on the sport was,
that's what it was.
We just did not win that.
I,
I saw myself back when the Patriots would always lose to the dolphins,
Dan Marino,
like we'd,
we'd finally sack them,
somehow,
finally sack them.
He'd be on the ground and be like,
fuck you.
Like we finally got him.
So,
um,
I took that as a,
uh,
a not of respect to the patriots as much as the plus the guy,
he's a real fan man,
if he's,
if he gives a shit that much.
Um,
so anyways,
I,
uh,
I'm out here.
I am,
uh,
I am manic right now because I am in a mild depression.
I missed my family so much and we'll try to get them to fly out here this week.
This is fucking ridiculous.
Um,
I gotta I gotta see my kid one way or another.
I got to see my kids.
So,
um,
I've just been,
I've just been fucking watching sports,
everybody,
that's all I've been doing.
I mean,
I know I always do it,
but like I literally was like,
what am I going to do on Saturday?
You know,
they don't shoot on weekends.
What am I going to do out here?
I don't know what the fuck to do with myself.
So I drove three hours up in three hours back.
I went to that Tennessee volunteer game against the,
um,
the South Carolina Gamecocks a messy,
she accident
[inaudible] paint.
I went up there and it was,
it was fucking awesome.
It was a great drive.
Um,
you know,
if you're a comedian,
you got to love driving after a while and he also got to love driving by
yourself.
You know,
if you're a,
if you're a comedian you don't like doing that,
you usually end up getting an acting career,
writing career or are you just fucking quit the business?
I don't know what it is,
but I've always enjoyed it.
So I had a great time driving up there.
I never drove from Atlanta and the Chattanooga up to fucking Knoxville.
I want to see what it looks like.
Um,
and I was driving up there,
it was a 12 noon games,
so I'd leave it like fucking quarter to eight in the morning.
Um,
but this is good cause it couldn't go all the way up there.
It's going to be three hours for the game in three hours to drive back.
By the time I get back,
I can still do a spot down the street at the club.
Ian Edwards is going to be down there.
One of the best fucking comedians in the country that nobody,
not enough people know about.
All right.
Like I looked up the other day,
I looked up this guitarists,
I found this guitar that you know,
was for the while,
was known as the greatest guitarist.
Nobody ever heard of like Danny,
uh,
gotten or something like that.
I got to get his fucking name right.
The guy's unbelievable.
And he's,
I mean,
unfortunately he's dead,
but uh,
you know,
guy was,
she was like a fucking jet.
Danny Gatton,
G A,
t.
T.
O.
N.
Look that guy up and there's this thing when he plays Austin city limits where
I'm going to be next week,
I'm at the new one,
not the one he was at.
They say he plays a song where they say with a beer can,
he actually does it with a beer bottle.
I've seen people do with the slide and all that,
but um,
watch what happens because the beer gets all over night starts,
you know,
there's beer in there.
So it starts fizzing up,
it gets all over his fretboard.
And then he puts a towel over the fretboard to dry it off while continuing to
play.
Um,
I've never seen,
I mean,
I've seen
a lot of tricks.
Uh,
it was fucking amazing.
So I'm Ian Edwards,
I'm telling you,
you gotta see,
you gotta see that guy.
It's just there's something wrong with our fucking business that more people
does it.
Don't know who that guy is.
So I was like,
I got to go down and go see him do a set.
And plus not only that,
that'll take up my whole fucking Saturday,
then I'll stay out late enough to come home,
fall asleep,
boom.
Done.
Right.
So anyways,
so I'm dry.
I'm driving up to northern fucking Georgia into sudden Tanner say,
and there's all this fucking traffic.
So the robot lady and my phone starts talking to me,
creeping me out,
telling me there's a quicker way.
It's just like,
Whoa,
how do you have time to pay attention to me?
Who are you?
But thank you.
So I get off the fucking road and I'm driving up north there and uh,
I went by this fucking house.
You know those houses where they,
somebody just has like 20 old cars sit in the front yard.
This fucking lunatic had like 30 not cars.
He had riding mowers.
Now like the landscape level ones,
like the ones like your dad had,
you know,
and you,
you try to fucking steal the keys to take it out or whatever.
You'd run over a friend of yours and he'd lose a foot or whatever,
you know,
that type of shit.
Jesus,
what's going on out here?
Oh Christ is the gay pride parade still going on?
Is Anything on Flyer?
Um,
they had the gay pride parade out here,
went right by the hotel yesterday and uh,
you know,
it's fucking funny.
There's always one guy who has to just ruin it,
you know what I mean?
There's always one guy that just ruins it for everybody else.
Like,
you know,
sports fans of cool.
And then just one douchebag at a panthers game has to turn around and blast a 63
year old guy in the face.
Not once,
not twice,
not three times a lady,
four fucking times.
At least they caught the guy.
Dude,
that guy is looking,
I think at some serious jail time.
Serious fucking jail time.
Uh,
you know,
the first two maybe get some fucking,
Andy Griffith,
lower Gamal,
you know,
emotions were running and had an act guy.
He shared allowed names,
calling him,
going back and forth.
You know,
we just go,
y'all got a little bit hold on Carol.
Right?
Maybe he could,
I don't know what,
just get him a couple like a month in jail or something.
It's the fact that they broke it up and he came back for those last two brutal.
Once Jesus Christ and help old people learned something out there.
Okay.
You know,
as much as it hurts your lower back,
you got to keep that head moving.
Can't,
you can't just be a stationary target.
Um,
he's God damn old people.
You know,
it's like you,
if you want to talk shit,
you gotta move your fucking head.
Um,
I'm sorry.
Anyways,
this fucking guy,
he had like 30 riding lawn mower sitting in his front yard.
I was doing like 70 miles an hour and I
drove past it and I wasn't going to stop because I was worried I wasn't going to
get to the game and time.
And it was fucking hilarious.
The ironic part was like the grass had all grown up around them.
Like th these front yard needed to be mowed,
but he couldn't mow it because he had snapped in all the fucking tractors.
You get people that there's a joke in there somewhere.
I just don't know where.
Um,
anyways,
I,
uh,
ended up getting up to,
into the stadium of the Tennessee game place.
I always wanted to go to,
um,
and it was fucking awesome.
And not only that,
as a freckled borderline albino con,
I picked the perfect row.
I called up stubhub and I told him,
I said,
I'm an old man who gets sunburned.
I want to be in the lower deck right above the roof of the,
Oh,
you know,
of the upper deck.
And The lady's like,
okay,
well you didn't think anything actually for once.
I looked at the,
the uh,
the stadium map,
you know,
and uh,
suddenly he's like,
is,
I know you don't give a fuck.
You just,
you just sold a ticket to a fucking World Cup game.
Now I'm,
I'm,
and I,
I brought you into Tennessee,
you know,
you don't even know where you're at.
So I went with row 57 and it was the perfect row.
It was the last fucking road at the sun.
Didn't touch cause I was on the visitors side.
Do you ever go to the stadium?
The Sun creeps up the visitor's side.
It goes down on the home side,
so it creeps all the way up to row 56 and at the end of the game it was,
it was on like from like mid calf down.
I fuck it.
I nailed it.
I mean actually if I did 58,
it would've been perfect.
But um,
it was just,
it was an awesome time.
One of the biggest stadiums I believe is the fifth largest stadium as far as the
amount of people that it holds.
And it's an old school stadium.
Fuck,
I didn't even have the nerve to go in the bathroom.
I just saw this door that looked like a fucking closet door and I was like,
there's a bathroom in there.
There's no way that's not pissed troughs in there and I am not peeing in a
fucking piss trough.
I'm not doing it.
And um,
I gotta tell you when you're on the lower level and you're walking through there
,
you feel like you're in a bunker.
If your cluster phobic,
I wouldn't do it.
Um,
I've got all these great pictures.
I,
I got a post a man,
they just like,
the stadium is so fucking cool and I have to go there.
You know,
they have a decent team.
I want to go there when,
uh,
to an sec game at night under the lights when it fucking matters.
Um,
underrated city,
Knoxville,
underrated Chattanooga,
Tennessee is the shit.
Um,
you go to Nashville,
Nashville is like Austin,
Texas where it is just everybody's moving or Atlanta,
everybody's just that just fucking overcrowded.
And um,
the two great cities.
So I went there,
you know,
the fucking bands playing.
You know,
there wasn't a bunch of screaming and yelling.
They didn't have giant flat screen fucking TVs and explosions and shit.
It was just,
it was like the old school just go into a game.
There was a hilarious guy in my section,
which there always is.
You just can't hear him.
Now when you go to a game,
there was this fucking big fat dude too.
There was a lot of fatties at the gay Tennessee.
What's going on up there?
Lay off the fucking barbecue.
Jesus Christ.
I could tell why you guys love those.
Fucking checkered overalls holds you fucking beer belly really nicely.
Um,
this guy was fucking hilarious.
He looked like he was dressed like herb Tarlek.
Um,
except it was all Tennessee gear and he was so fucking amped up for the game and
he was getting the section going and he would always get right up to the
borderline is,
is this guy fucking nuts.
And then he'd look at him,
he'd have this shit eating grin on his face,
like laughing at himself,
knowing that he was nuts,
that he was getting this amped up for the game.
But,
um,
it was a great game and I stayed till the end,
like my mother taught me and it came right down to the last play.
I fucking,
you know,
I video taped it while I looked over so I could watch it,
live and not look at it.
So my screen,
mmm.
And it looks like the guy had a chance.
I wouldn't let it look like it went right to his,
his,
uh,
his fingers in it.
It didn't work,
whatever.
And then I drove fucking back.
I came down here,
I went down to the laughing skull and I got to watch the Great Ian Edwards just
fucking blew me away.
I'm telling you right now,
if you get a chance to see that guy live,
you got to do it.
You've got to do it before it blows up.
Uh,
hung out with him.
Some of his friends got a grilled cheese sandwich and some French fries late
night out.
Jesus just eating like a fat chick on Prom night.
MMM.
I'm depressed.
All right.
Fucking
okay.
Dealing with this shit.
Um,
so anyways,
so that was that day.
So then Sunday comes along like,
well,
how am I going to kill this day?
A loneliness.
And it's like,
oh shit.
The Atlanta Falcons are home.
They got a fucking home game.
Shit.
They playing the dolphins.
Fucking Jake Cutler,
I'm going to go see,
I've already saw them play against the rams is she know the,
the charges this year I'll go down and go checkup and evidently the,
uh,
the fucking falcons have this new dome stadium that's going to be unbelievable.
So I was like,
all right,
I'll go to this fucking game.
Last time I was here was in fucking
2004.
I saw,
uh,
Michael Vick back when he was drowning the dogs and nobody knew the most
electrifying fucking football player I ever saw.
Every time you went out of the pocket,
the whole stadium stood up like it was the last play of the championship game in
a Hail Mary was coming.
Um,
place would go crazy,
right?
So I'm a guy,
I'm going to go all the,
I don't have a ticket.
I'll be like,
all right,
I'm just,
I'll scalp a ticket.
I'll sit at the top of the stadium.
Who gives a fuck?
So I get over there and there's like no scalpers and I'm like,
what the fuck?
Oh No,
no,
I didn't.
The Gay Pride Parade and walked through the Gay Pride Parade.
I got to get back to the,
the one guy who ruins it.
So it's typical gay pride parade,
much people fucking rainbows on the faces.
You know,
a couple guys walk around and high heel shoes,
gay pride parade.
Everybody's having a good time.
What's not the fucking like,
right?
There's always the one dude who has to ruin it.
This fucking jerk off
is standing there on the side of the road.
He has like a fucking giant Dick and balls like balloon animal.
That was his like three quarters to sides of his body.
This giant pink erect fucking Dick with balls.
And it's just like,
dude,
this kid's here,
this fuck.
What is wrong with you?
This is what blows my mind is you're,
you're able to do that at the gay pride parade.
I'm trying to think of a parade that I could go to with a giant inflated vagina
with kids around and just in public.
I just don't think he could do it.
But anyways,
hey,
I'm trying to be progressive.
God bless this guy with this giant Dick and balls like fucking twisted up
balloon in them.
I actually had to wonder if that was like a plant from the religious right to
show all gay people represent them as like that there's just see sexually
deviant fucking people,
you know,
like you always see those conspiracy theories that they have.
You know,
whenever there's a peaceful demonstration,
they sent somebody down there to throw a rock through a window just to get
everybody going to start writing.
So they,
you know,
all the people protesting get to be lumped in with that one dose.
Um,
so whatever.
So I totally judged this guy with this giant fucking balloon twisted Dick and
balls going,
what are fucking,
what the fuck is wrong with?
How the fuck was this guy raised?
Blahblahblahblahblah smash cut to me.
Not even 20 minutes later when I find this no scalpers and I go up to the
fucking Wilke one of the ticket windows,
they say they're sold out.
And the only way to get a ticket is I have to go on my phone to Ticketmaster and
I have no idea how to do this.
I've avoided computers.
I don't know.
I don't,
I just,
I'm bad with the shit.
You know what I mean?
You know,
like,
like me trying to figure out this shit is like to ask somebody like somebody
tone deaf to sing a fucking song,
you know,
it's just,
you can't do it.
Right.
So,
uh,
could you tell I got a text message in the middle of that.
I didn't even finish off whatever funny thought it was trying to have,
they're mildly amusing thought I was trying to have.
So anyways,
I fucking get over the stadium and now I've got to figure out this tick
Ticketmaster thing.
So I walk away like,
and just like cursing my fucking brains out.
Fucking God.
Damn fucking cock sucking buck Rogers fucking cut the bullshit walking by kids
and shit.
And I see parents looking at me like,
dude,
what the fuck?
And in the way,
in the back of my head is that voice of reason.
Hey Bill.
Now there's no reason to get this,
to get this crazy.
Come on,
really it in this children here.
And I just did the fucking demon in me,
just fucking country.
So I sit down like a little fucking boy,
like a little like the little fucking baby than I am Jesus Christ built,
download the fucking APP and figure it out.
Trying to figure out it's not working.
I'm,
I'm just,
every time it wouldn't work,
I'm like,
dude,
what the fuck?
I would literally yell that loud people walking by looking like,
what the fuck is wrong with that guy?
Right?
And finally,
uh,
some twentysomething security kid came walking by with his yellow coat.
I was just like,
dude,
I'm an old bastard.
I don't know how to do this.
Can you help me out with this?
And it was just like,
yeah,
just click on this.
Click on this,
click on that again.
All right,
there it is.
There's a ticket.
And I'm just sitting there looking at it saying,
I'm like,
this is a ticket.
He's like,
yeah,
it's a ticket.
I go,
what do I do?
And he just laughed and he goes,
just bring your phone.
And then they scan it.
I'm like,
this is going to work.
And he's like,
yeah.
So now I'm standing in line.
I have so little faith that technology is,
is gonna.
It's gonna work for me.
All I could think of was midnight express in the beginning of the movie when the
dude has the drugs tape to them like,
I'm going to get,
this isn't going to work.
They're going to,
they're going to get like,
they're going to toss me out of the fucking stadium and I'm going to be out this
whatever,
a hundred bucks or whatever.
I paid for this ticket and I went up,
I,
they scanned it and it worked and I was like,
wow,
I'll have to fuck it worked.
Then I was just like,
well,
well was what the f how do I add this to my,
all my stack of tickets?
Do I got to fucking put my phone in there now?
Do I take a picture of it and then print it out on my printer and then that's
the ticket.
I don't get it.
So anyways,
I go into this stadium and Jesus Christ,
I'm telling you,
you got to fucking go to this stadium.
This is the best NFL stadium out there.
It is like,
I mean my,
my top of the new ones before that,
I mean you've got to go cowboys stadium even though that TV is just so fucking
big and obnoxious.
It's actually stu,
they took the TV out of there.
The cowboys,
I think they would like,
you know what I mean?
The cowboys stadium is like,
I dunno.
Do you ever see like a beautiful woman that's just absolutely shit faced and
she's got like fucking lipstick on her teeth and red wine breath and you just
like,
oh my God,
she's,
you know,
and she's a 10,
but you're like,
get the fuck away from me.
Right.
That's what the cowboys stayed.
That's what that TV is just fucks up the whole stadium and the Seahawks have a
great stadium.
Um,
even though they're cheating,
making the crowd sound louder than it is.
But anyways,
um,
speaking of cheaters to fucking Atlanta Falcons who got caught pumping a crowd
noise in,
so I'm at the this cheaters,
right?
Um,
I mean,
this stadium dude,
it's fucking breathtaking.
It's one of the cleanest design.
Sickest fucking on like Jerry Jones is going to be upset if,
yeah,
I'm sure you see God on his private plane.
You know,
getting botox injections on the way over there.
I'm sure when he walked in now these God damn motherfuckers,
right?
These God damn motherfuckers need probably fucking,
I dunno,
God help the woman that he's banging that weekend.
Jerry,
I just don't understand what I'm doing wrong.
Oh,
shut the fuck up.
Bitch
is
taken out.
Everything on her.
Dude,
that stadium is fucking,
I felt like I was in a spaceship.
It was fucking awesome.
I'm like,
you know,
and it was great.
I'm missing my family.
I'm,
I'm down there.
I'm just like,
oh good,
good.
Now I'm in a good mood
and dude,
I am sitting at the top of the stadium and it's still fucking awesome.
Maybe I was so fucking high up on the place,
what happened?
And he could kind of just,
just watch the whole defense.
You know?
I love doing that.
When you go to a game,
when you sit up high,
just watching the defense,
he kind of have like in your peripheral where the ball's going and just trying
to see it.
All the linemen,
if they come down and try to like pick up a linebacker or something like that,
or like a,
you know,
try to figure out which receivers open.
I'm a nerd.
I love doing that shit.
However,
I got to tell you something,
that the experience of going into that game,
I get that the NFL cares,
but Jesus Christ,
I think the NFL has kind of forgot that sports is like an escape.
Yeah.
You know what I mean?
Especially now with social media and all that shit.
You just can't get away with all the fucking,
yeah.
Uh Huh.
Just all the fucking shit that's going,
my God,
this,
this city just got hit by a fucking hurricane.
This made when we got Puerto Rico.
Then why?
Why is it,
why aren't they getting help out there?
You know what I mean?
All these veterans that come back,
they commit suicide,
blah,
blah.
All this fucking shit.
It's just,
it's fucking brutal.
So what do you do?
You need to shut it off for a,
you go to a fucking game.
But there's,
this was the experience at the Atlanta game.
First of all,
dude,
it was so fucking loud in there.
And to just take all this with a grain of salt,
because I'm a,
I'm an old cut.
All right.
I get in.
It was so fucking loud.
MMM.
They have these giant flat screens up at the top,
all going around in a circle.
And they were amazing.
I don't think that they're too big and they're not hanging down in your face,
so they're not really that distracting or anything.
But it was like the cheerleaders came out and they fucking were playing this
music.
I felt like I was at an ACDC concert.
It was that fucking loud
and [inaudible]
all of a sudden like Sam Jackson,
no,
no.
Wait before that,
way before that little John and another,
uh,
Atlanta rapper,
I don't,
I mean I'm white.
You Shit.
I don't know who the fuck this guy is.
Um,
I'm sure he's great.
Whatever they did,
like a public service announcement on fan behavior.
All right.
Which I'm sure is based off the one client who fucking punched the 62 year old
guy four times in the [inaudible]
face.
So now we got to get a lecture on how to be human beings and they just sit
there,
go like,
ah,
you know,
don't,
uh,
you know,
don't be discourteous to the people next to you.
It was funny.
It was really bland copy and watch a little John trying to like add something to
it was hilarious.
Uh,
Eddie fight at one point they say,
don't say anything racial.
I believe that's what they was saying.
It was so loud.
It was echoing and I couldn't hear it.
And then there was something about not saying anything politically charged.
Now it's just like,
where the fuck am I right now?
Who the fuck gives them up?
Gives a shit about politics.
I'm at a football game.
Who gives a fuck?
I'm trying to think back
when I was a kid,
when I went to a Bruins patriots game or something like that,
you know,
in the late eighties,
I don't ever remember anybody yelling out shit about Mike Dukakis versus George
Bush Sr.
MMM.
Anyways,
let me get back to this guy real quick.
Um,
yeah,
so they sent to the,
this whole fucking thing happens and then the fucking cheerleaders come out and
they're playing some fucking crazy loud ag ag,
ag ag.
Well,
pappy bleed fucking Dj Shit.
They're out there dancing,
shaking their ass.
I literally had my fingers in my ears like Jesus Christ,
I should have brought earplugs to this fucking thing.
And then out of nowhere,
Sam Jackson starts fucking screaming at everybody to get up something about the
heartbeat.
You know,
we've got to fucking do this.
First of all,
it's like Sam Jackson,
you're from New York.
When did you start giving a shit about the falcons?
You know what I mean?
I mean,
you would think he had enough capital one money to take a fucking weekend.
All the guys in star wars,
he is like capital one.
He's every way you want to be.
Right?
It's fucking guy's screaming and he's doing the whole fucking like it was
something about a heartbeat.
He yelled some shit,
we gotta fucking got out data and then this giant heartbeat would go,
go God deafening.
And then they'd cut to like,
you know,
and when,
when it was like beating that we cut to like an allowed Atlanta Falcon,
like thumping his chest mean mugging you.
And I'm just like,
dude,
I'm not playing.
I don't need to get this amped up screaming and fucking yelling.
That was so loud and so fucking distracting that I didn't even notice that the
fucking players had taken the field.
And what alerted me that the players had taken the field was after capital one,
Sam Jackson had stopped screaming.
And the heartbeat,
it ended,
all of a sudden I hear a locomotive train horn,
it just goes [inaudible] loud as shit.
And they kicked the ball off.
So it was the cheerleader,
Dat Yang,
can't get Sam Jackson,
get the fuck up your mother fuckers,
you know?
And then [inaudible] and after all of that shit,
the fucking ball just goes out to the back of the end zone and then they
announced it just goes touch back Atlanta.
Yeah.
So I burst out laughing and the lady next to me starts laughing and I,
and I looked at her like she saw what I saw and thought it was funny and she was
just laughing because I made her uncomfortable because I was at the game by
myself and I just burst out laughing.
So I think I came off as like a crazy person.
All right.
And then,
uh,
then I,
and then,
and then all this shit starts happening.
Okay.
And intertwined with all of this is like the trail of tears that for some reason
the NFL,
I don't know what they're trying to do.
Yeah.
I understand that there's a lot of people suffering in the world.
I get it.
I do benefits.
I give to charities,
you know,
I,
I try to do my fucking part.
I don't know what the solution is.
I don't know why we can't get along.
I don't know why there's disease and all that,
but we,
but what we do have is we have music and we have sports,
and it's a way to kind of get away from it.
Right.
This is what
the fuck I saw at the game.
Okay.
The game starts
okay.
And they have a veteran who's missing a leg runs out with the flag.
Okay.
Which is uplifting,
but also depressing.
He lost his leg.
I'm like,
ah,
fuck these fucking kids,
man.
This whole fucking generation generations at this point,
we gotta be in the second generation.
That's all.
Were they fighting fucking wars?
Why?
Why,
why do we try to solve things this way?
It's poor fucking guy,
man.
He's losing all the Mr is lost the leg.
All right,
so I'm thinking about people losing limbs in the war.
The lady goes out,
the lay goes out to sing the national anthem.
That was so fucking loud when they announced,
I forget where to cause was.
There was some sort of ribbon and it was cancer related.
So we've got the one legged vet and then I'm like,
God,
fuck the veterans are cheeses.
Christ got,
how do we get out of this fucking war?
Right?
I'm thinking about that.
Then I'm thinking about people with cancer and then the coin toss.
They bring this cute little boy out,
nine year old kid or something who survived bone marrow cancer,
and then I start thinking,
oh my God,
what if my,
that's horrible.
What if my kid ever got cancer?
How would I handle that or would I do?
Oh my God,
if my kid died,
I'd fucking kill myself.
I stopped.
I'm thinking suicidal fucking thoughts here.
All right.
Then the fucking game starts.
Wow.
Thought about the blender,
right?
They're playing all this shit loud is fucking Shit,
Eh,
I'm trying to shake off all the misery of the world that I've been reminded of
like five different examples.
And then out of nowhere
this,
they show this one,
they show this guy on the screen and then they showed this woman who's married
to the guy and she's now a widow because the dude died in Afghanistan.
And I'm like,
oh my God,
she lost her husband.
Oh,
that poor woman,
that's fucking terrible.
And then they cut to her wearing an Atlantic Falcons Jersey with their two kids
who are now fatherless wearing the Jersey smiling and waving at this giant
fucking flat screen.
And all I'm thinking is like,
those fucking kids are gonna grow up without a father.
Second doubted three Atlanta.
Right?
I'm just like,
what the f what is going on here?
It was one of the most depressing do.
There was like nine minutes left in the first quarter.
And in case you missed the veteran running out with one leg,
they fucking showed that again.
Yeah.
And,
uh,
all I can think at that point.
It's like what does the halftime show going to be?
Am I going to watch somebody die in an iron lung?
Well,
their family members holding hands crying and then the PA announcer,
it'd be like,
yeah,
that's right.
Look at it and look at that misery.
Do you pay more?
I realize how lucky you are.
Okay.
You don't have to spend your life for your own personal separate.
I only got an ax.
Halan,
my Jesus Christ NFL.
Why?
Why stop there?
How about every time they fucking throw the ball,
you show me that cow that was slaughtered so they could have this skin.
Any time they shoot tee shirts into the crowd,
why don't you just show me the fucking sweatshop labor that,
that put it together.
You know what it is?
Caring is a great fucking thing.
But how about you pick a cause rather than they,
I mean what did they show in the,
I mean I left,
I left with like five minutes left in the second quarter.
It was just like,
you know what?
This is a great stadium.
I want to be here with a friends and shit.
Yeah.
And uh,
I'm already depressed that I'm on the fucking road.
I'm missing my family.
I came here to get away from that sadness and I've been reminded that I'm kind
of being selfish because these people have way bigger sadness than I do.
And somewhere in all of that I saw
balloon fucking Dick and balls,
twisted fucking balloon animals while kids were walking by.
I'll tell you it was a hell of a day,
you know.
So I actually,
and I saw that the jets were fucking coming at the pats and I was like,
why don't I just go sit in a fucking bar and,
and watch this thing.
This is the other thing too.
Like
I,
I just,
I just don't 100% by
that.
The fucking NFL truly cares that much.
You know what I mean?
Cause you know they got busted whenever they show a veteran in the crowd.
We had one of our heroes here,
but Baba Baba,
Baba,
the whatever branch of the service they're showing,
they have to pay the NFL.
They considered a recruitment video like,
like a commercial.
And I heard they recently adjusted it.
I don't know,
but what the fuck?
Right.
And how much fucking money do you have to make?
So I believe the owners individually,
I believe that they all care about these causes.
I'm sure all of them have had,
you know,
friends or whatever,
fighting in wars had been touched.
You know,
unfortunately you had a family or a family member or a friend that got cancer or
something like that.
But I really have to believe that just because it is a corporation and that the
way that they handled in the way that they've handled their players,
you know what I mean?
But all the brain damage and shit and they just fucking ignored it allegedly
after they knew about it.
And then when they did the class action suit against the NFL,
they basically gave every player like 800 or a thousand bucks.
Um,
it just comes off like a PR move like that.
They feel that they can grow their brand.
This is my conspiracy theory.
I'm not saying I'm right.
I think the NFL resents soccer that it's,
and the UFC that started well after them that also went global.
I think they want to go global and I think they've reached the maximum amount of
sports fans.
So now they're trying to grow their brand through carrying,
everybody's trying to show how much they care or maybe it's a symptom of this
fucking social media craziness
where everybody's like,
I dunno just going nuts,
screaming and yelling at people.
MMM.
That they try to get out in front of it and care about every cause that's out
there.
I have no fucking idea,
but all I know is I went to that game,
you know,
going,
all right,
let me kill a day here and forget that.
How much I'm missing my wife and my kid.
And I went there and it's just like,
wow.
I guess the good thing was I realized I don't have a lot,
I don't have,
my troubles aren't as big as other people's troubles,
but Jesus fucking Christ and it fell.
How about you just pick one,
pick one.
I like,
you know,
the Fred socks always had the Jimmy Fund.
You know,
they had that and it was,
that was it.
That was,
I mean Jesus,
it was fucking unreal.
So,
um,
anyways,
having said that,
you got to go to the store,
it's got to go to the steady.
All right.
Um,
but I would,
before you go to the Falcon Stadium,
I would recommend you watch raising Arizona Watch something really funny.
Get yourself in a,
in a really elevated mood because they are going to bring you down.
They are going to bring you fucking down Jesus Christ.
You know,
I'm the only thing that they will,
you know,
and plus it's also like what they choose to care about is really fucking like
planned out too.
Like I'm waiting for one of those NFL teams to bring out a bunch of fucking
recovered heroin addicts that got addicted to pain pills that they got to the
pharmaceutical industry that is allegedly basically synthetic heroin dealers.
Why don't they show that?
Oh that's right.
Cause pharmaceutical companies advertise
on those network and they're not going to show that shit.
They're not going to bite the hand that feeds.
They're not going to go on.
Why do people keep getting cancer?
Why is cancer through the fucking roof?
Let's look at pesticides.
Let's look at what we're doing to our food supply has stay away from that.
Stay away from that.
I'm big on the military,
big on the military to the point literally of like,
I felt in a way that I was sort of in like a clockwork orange and they should
have just had my eyes taped open as they're selling me,
you know,
our foreign policy like squirting tears into my eyes.
It's just like,
you know,
it's like guys,
what's your getting involved with is way more complex than a football game.
Okay.
So just keep it simple,
stupid.
It's,
people have always told me.
So anyways,
that was my experience.
Um,
overall it was a great experience.
I feel bad that I left the fucking game.
My mother always taught me never to leave the game and I left and the dolphins
came back and won.
And um,
oh,
by the way,
he was another loud thing.
Anytime it was third down,
this is fucking,
anytime we started down this fucking lunatic would just go,
uh,
sorry
to get the crowd like amped up.
And it's just like,
dude,
I have a flat screen TV in front of me that is easily two and a half times the
size of my fucking house.
And it says third and two.
I can see it.
MMM.
I Dunno.
But having said all that,
um,
I'm going to give a shout out here to the,
whoever the fuck designed that fucking stadium.
It is unbelievable.
It's gorgeous.
And the college Superbowl is there this year.
She wants to blow some fucking money and the Superbowl's going to be there next
year.
It's fucking amazing.
Um,
it's amazing.
And the NFL cares,
you know,
it's another great one is Ford Ford Motor Company.
They got a tie out there where they go 100% of the proceeds go to fight cancer,
which is great cause a lot of times it's a portion of the proceeds and they keep
a lot of it.
So I will commend Ford for that.
But what's hilarious is,
is their website is suddenly like Ford cares.com.
It's like,
well it's glad.
I'm glad you care about that.
Cause you certainly didn't give a fuck where you put the gas tank and the Pinto
and the crown Vic.
Did Ya?
Um,
anyways.
All right.
That's it.
I'm done with my sports rants here.
But uh,
thank you to the NFL and thank you to the world of college sports.
You guys got me through this fucking weekend.
The loneliness.
Uh,
thank you to the new punchline in Atlanta.
Yeah.
Um,
I got to do a spot there last night and the laughing skull down the street.
I've been having a great time trying to stay sharp with my act and uh,
I guys,
I can't tell you the name of them.
I don't,
I don't know what I can,
I can't talk about the movie that I'm in,
but I think,
I think this one's going to be a fucking good one,
dude.
I am like really excited looking at all of like,
mmm.
The shots that the direct,
I want to say the director's name cause I never know what the fuck you can't see
and can't see it.
But the fucking shots that I've been seeing,
it's literally I'm sitting like,
dude,
I'm going to be fucking in this thing now.
Watch.
They're going to cut my,
cut my part out.
What am I going to learn to keep my fucking mouth shut?
All right.
You know what?
Let's uh,
let's do a little advertising here.
All right.
What do we got here?
Um,
me undies.
Everybody.
Me On ds.
All me undies.
Stop showing people die in the new dude beyond these me on days.
I'm at a football game.
Why am I crying?
I get dead.
People have fucking cancer.
People die in wars.
Don't wear from can I just watch this fucking game?
You NFL,
greedy con.
Stop acting like your care.
All right,
me undies makes Andries de your butt will be proud to wear and check this out.
I'm not the only one who loves me undies.
Listen to what my long time listener in me undies enthusiasts.
George has to say a note from George N,
a bill burr listener in me undies fan.
What fucking big brother's shit is this.
I've never met this guy.
Anyways,
this guy said,
and there's no last name,
how do we know this person exists?
George and George?
Nonexistent.
I decided to try out me undies because I love Bill Burns me undies,
jingles.
I smile every time he sings it.
Somehow I feel like the cleaned this up.
Yeah,
I smile.
I bet he really said Dad,
I liked the way he sings to fucking songs.
Dude,
I fucking laugh my balls off.
Then they clean it all up.
I smile every time he thinks it.
Second of three.
Atlanta.
Uh,
although it's so easy to skip ads in a podcast,
I always listened to bill's reads and I'm so glad me undies has stuck with them.
I've been,
it's been probably two years since I first bought a pair of me undies and now I
have a monthly subscription because they are that comfortable.
I swear to God,
this is their copy.
This isn't me doing the like the Atlantic Falcons,
the Atlanta Falcons,
things like,
look at me hooking up a widow.
Look at me.
Look how much my listeners love my reads.
Anyways,
before me undies,
I used to buy the three pack of underwear at retail stores.
Do this as so edited.
There's no way this was written this perfectly until I realized that I wanted to
treat my junk on.
There you go.
Maybe it's shrimp to something more comfortable and that starts with a great
pair of me undies,
cradling my family jewels.
Yeah,
that was totally rewritten.
Anyways,
to get 20% off the softest,
most cradling jewel underwear you can ever get,
um,
and socks you will ever own.
Alright,
you feed will be happy.
You balls will be happy and your knees will be jealous.
Free Shipping and 100% satisfaction guarantee.
Go to [inaudible] dot com slash [inaudible] that's [inaudible] dot com slash
burr oh look who's here.
Everybody Dollar Shave Club,
dude.
Dude,
everyone knows that dollar shave club ships amazing raises for a few bucks.
Kid.
What you might not fucking know.
It's still highly shave club has products for pretty much every fucking thing
you need.
The bathroom,
body wash,
shampoo,
Hair Gel,
lip balm,
fucking everything too.
You want to do a bump?
They got a little dial shape,
kind of pride can cocaine spoon.
Um,
if you're sick of the nonsense at the store,
this still one,
two,
three,
four.
Let's all go to this stew.
Now's the time to try out dollar shave club for a limited time.
Dollar Shave Club is basically giving away their shit.
Shower,
shave status set to new members.
Shit,
shower shave static kit to new members for only $5.
It started said features that are executive razor and three trial size versions
of their most popular products that help you stay so fresh and so clean.
Boop,
boop,
boop.
Get my fucking nuts.
So fresh and so clean.
Um,
in your first box you will receive their shave butter,
bodywash and one wipe cheat.
Ah,
please.
Jolly says like my love to wipe my booty.
But what wipes are you will also receive their executive razor,
which includes their premium,
weighty handle and full consent of cartridges.
After the first box replacement cartridges are sent for only a few bucks a
month.
This offer is exclusively available@dollarshaveclub.com slash burr that's dollar
shave club.com/bird dollar shave club's high quality products.
We'll have you covered from face cheeks to butt cheeks.
All right,
what do I got here?
stamps.com stamps save you time and money,
which you can use to grow your business.
I can mail any letter,
any package using just my computer and printer and the mailman picks it up.
Avoid the hassle to the Po of the post office and mail everything from postcards
to envelope or envelopes to package packages,
domestic or international.
Create your stamps account minutes online with no equipment to lease and no
longterm commitments.
Click print and mail and you're done.
Dude.
Unlike the post office stamps.com never closes.
Print postage for letters at uh,
or packages at your convenience.
24 seven keywords.
Descriptors at key,
I guess I'm supposed to say it's convenient,
easy,
reliable and flexible.
Just like dead who are down the street.
Uh,
I use stamps.com because I don't know.
It's fucking easy.
I'm a moron if I can figure out how to do it.
So can you,
and right now you,
you too can enjoy the stamps.com service with a special offer that includes a
four week trial plus postage and a digital scale without a longterm commitment.
Yeah,
go to stamps.com.
Click on the
microphone@thetopofthehomepageandtypeinburgerthatstampsdotcomandrubberstamps.com
.
Never go to the post office again.
All right.
Hey,
guess what?
I started watching yesterday on Netflix.
I watched,
I watched the first episode of Narcos and uh,
I was funny,
I tried to watch it the first time and I don't know,
but I think the subtitles,
I got intimidated because in the beginning there's this,
they have this whole fucking thing about magical mysticism or some bullshit like
that and it's on the screen,
whatever the paragraph is before that,
it goes by too fucking quick.
I can't read it.
And then I'm just like,
okay,
this is going to be the pace of the reading.
I'm not going to be able to keep up with it.
Well anyways,
I'm lonely on the road.
I finally figured out my Netflix account.
It's fucking hilarious.
I've got a show on Netflix and I never watch it because I,
I just,
I dunno,
I don't interact well with computers in all of this shit.
And then once it's passwords,
I'm going to forget the password and then I'm going to say,
email me my password and then somehow it's going to end up in my junk folder and
I won't be able to find it.
I just figured,
you know what?
Fuck it.
I'll just put on my TV and watch the Rockford files,
right.
Well,
I finally figured it out and I watched the first episode of Narcos and I'm 100%
in what a goddamn show.
Also,
by the way,
uh,
the producers of the show,
whatever the production company,
whenever you say is gold mine,
which also does theF is for family,
I'll fucking great today.
Um,
so anyways,
uh,
when I watched that first fucking episode,
when he's sitting there talking to those army guys and starts naming their
names,
mmm.
When Pablo Escobar is doing that and he starts,
you know,
just letting them know that he knows all of their families members and like
basically,
you know,
without saying that something bad's going to happen to them,
I still don't understand why they just didn't take a gun and blow his fucking
brains out.
There's no loyalty
in,
uh,
in that world.
Once you fucking killed him,
then,
then they would
cut the head off the snake.
I'm,
I know I'm over simplifying this,
but I'm just saying,
if there's any DAA agents that are listening here,
if he just blew his fucking brains out right then and there wouldn't all the
other gangsters underneath them,
one to then be the next Pablo Escobar's and then they would start fighting with
each other,
wouldn't that happen?
And then they would have to establish than they would have to pay out.
They'd have to start all over again.
Like,
Hey,
we had to deal with Pablo.
He paid us off.
You didn't,
you know,
when it start all over again and then they wouldn't have time to come after your
family.
I know.
I probably totally fucking over simplified that fucking thing that night.
Um,
all right,
well,
how much time do we have left here?
Oh,
Bill,
he's got to hit the fucking treadmill.
All right.
Keep his little fucking,
you know,
Evan Been Busan.
I've been doing all right.
I haven't been doing the greatest,
I've been fucking,
I'm not gonna lie to you.
I'm a,
I'm in a fucking mild depression right now.
And,
uh,
but I'm going to see my,
my wife and my daughter this week,
hopefully.
Um,
okay.
I mean,
if someone I'm going to,
I'm going to get them out here.
All right.
Uh,
okay.
Let's,
let's read some of the fucking,
oh,
wait a minute.
Get an all things comedy festival podcast read.
That's right.
I'm doing my first live Monday morning podcast.
This could be a total fucking train wreck no matter what.
It's going to be exciting.
Uh,
we're having our first all things comedy festival at the end of the month.
October 26th through the 29th in Phoenix,
Arizona.
I'll be there recording my first ever live Monday morning podcast.
The great legendary Doug Stan hope is doing his podcast at the Orpheum theater.
Um,
Bert Kreischer are reshift fear and the crab feast are also on the lineup.
We're taking over downtown Phoenix with the pop up podcast studio and the whole
network is going to be there.
If you're in the Phoenix area,
come and hang out with us.
Go to all things,
comedy.com.
Get your tickets.
Absolutely.
I'm going to be walking around fucking shaking hands,
kissing babies,
right?
Doing public service announcements on a giant flat screen TV reminding you that
people still get to Berkeley or losis.
Anything I can do to depress you at our podcast and I'm not gonna,
I'm not going to do that.
Um,
afterwards I'll do a meet and greet at the end of the fucking,
uh,
you know,
at the end of the,
uh,
the man podcast,
whatever the live fucking thing,
you know,
I'll do all of that bullshit.
Um,
unless I have a really bad show and then I'll just go in the back and cry.
all right,
let's get to the questions here.
All right,
Bill,
did everyone know about Harvey Weinstein and then parentheses from a lady?
All right.
I don't know why I had to let me know it was from a woman.
Okay.
Hey,
bill,
I'm a big fan of your podcast and your show I saw in Montreal earlier this year
was epic.
Seeing a master at work is a beautiful thing.
Ah,
yeah.
Buttered me up.
You buttered me up.
I have a lot of respect for you as a straight forward guy.
Oh,
it looks out.
This person's brilliant.
She's gone.
You know,
you're a fucking brilliant away.
You do.
I know that.
You never lie.
This is great.
This is the way you ask a question.
If you want to get an understand,
sir.
Uh,
you're one of the few,
I'll believe unequivocally on this subject.
Do you think everyone in Hollywood knew about Harvey Weinstein?
I can totally understand how no one spoke out until now.
He was fucking scary and clearly had the precedents pocket.
I'd like to think I would have spoken out,
but honestly,
I probably would have put my fucking life in career on the line with little
chance of taking him down.
I just wish all this stars feigning shock would just be honest and admit they
knew they didn't have the balls,
parentheses or were too smart to step up.
We'd love to hear neos thoughts on this.
So,
and I,
she's not here.
Congratulations on your amazing Tada.
Love hearing about you being in dead.
Go Fuck Yourself.
Um,
all right.
First of all,
thank you for talking to me as if I'm on the big star level and I know it all of
them think,
um,
I gotta be honest with you.
I didn't know a fucking thing about that guy other than he had a lot of hit
movies.
MMM.
I came up as a standup comedian and have risen to the having a vulgar animated
show on Netflix.
That's,
that's the level I got to.
So I've done some movies
okay.
With some pretty big people,
but his name never came up,
so,
okay.
If I had a guest,
I imagine a lot of people knew that he fucked around in his wife.
This is all speculation.
MMM.
I have no idea,
but I don't know.
Okay.
I think the women that he did it too,
obviously,
you know,
allegedly you got to say a legend.
Now I'm trying to get sued here.
It's still all allegedly has not been convicted of the
58 people that came out with the same fucking story.
It's all allegedly,
um,
I'd have to think that they knew and then their friends would know.
But how far it goes from that.
It's,
it's,
it's a,
I don't know.
I have no idea.
I ain't go to be honest with you.
We were in between takes and,
uh,
on the movie and we were shooting in this fucking really cool fucking motel man.
I felt like I was in a Coen brothers movie,
so one of the rooms we had was like the little green room and they will,
they,
the story was on and these women were coming forward and like
my mouth was literally a gape listening to it.
I,
I can't,
I be honest,
I'll,
I can straight from me.
I can't fucking believe somebody could do that and get away with it for that
fucking law.
I mean.
Okay.
And did the tape,
that fucking woman
and how that isn't enough
I guess.
Cause he never said yes.
I grabbed,
yeah,
your boob.
I think he just keeps going.
Like I understand.
Just come and say,
I just got,
I,
I'm used to this.
None of that is an admission.
Yeah.
All right.
Then one more just because you're used to this,
like,
okay,
I dunno,
I just got to be on with you.
It's the most disgusting fucking thing I've ever heard in my life.
And if this guy is as guilty as he looks,
I'm worried that he's not going to go to jail
because I don't know what evidence there is.
And,
and the,
this statute of limit limitations.
I,
you know,
you going back decades with the shit,
I don't know how it fucking works.
Uh,
but in a perfect world,
they'd take them out to the desert and they put two bind his fucking ear.
I mean,
if he's guilty,
if he's innocent,
and I think I just fucked my whole career.
Um,
I have,
I have no idea.
I don't know who knew what or whatever,
but I will tell you,
I've been enjoying watching Fox News,
having a field day with this trashing Hollywood.
Um,
and you know,
given that guy was in the fucking hot tub with a 13 year old girls now hides out
in France,
giving him an award and all that shit.
Uh,
I love watching them called Hollywood out.
I love watching Hannity,
calling out the hypocrisy of Hollywood,
you know,
trashing Donald Trump for what the fuck he's doing while bad shit's going on in
their own town.
And then all the wild Hannity never bringing up below Riley while saying that
the friend,
what the fuck is that guy?
I always forget his name,
the French dude there,
whatever guy had out in
France or whatever saying,
and they gave this guy in a ward afterwards and it's just like,
yeah.
And you had bill O'Reilly on your show afterward.
So everybody is like,
I dunno.
It's just such a fucking amazing time
for that shit.
Hillary Clinton complaining about the fucking,
uh,
electorial college while the Democratic Party went to court and admitted that
Bernie Sanders got more votes,
but they colluded with Hillary's,
uh,
you know,
campaign to be like,
no,
you give us the best shot,
so we're going to pick you.
Fuck with the people say,
I don't know.
I don't fucking know.
And then me saying that I fucking hate listening to people to talk politics.
And then here I am talking.
Uh,
yeah,
I have no idea who knew what.
But I would definitely say that,
you know,
uh,
the same way like Fox News,
there's no fucking way.
They didn't know that Bill O'reilly was settling out of court in these fucking
things.
You know,
this same way that there's no way at the Weinstein company,
they didn't know something was amiss.
MMM.
I just don't,
I don't,
I'd be honest with you.
I am as shocked as anybody else.
I just don't fucking get it.
I,
I don't,
uh,
I don't understand.
It's just one of the worst fucking things.
It's,
I,
you know,
I have no,
I don't have any jokes.
It's just one of the most disgusting fucking things I've ever heard.
And,
uh,
I don't want to pay attention to the story because I don't think he's going to
go to jail and listening to his comments.
He's the typical piece of shit that does stuff like that where he actually feels
like the victim,
you know what I mean?
Um,
he's making it about himself and how bad he feels,
you know,
fuck the victims,
whatever the alleged victims,
what,
and I don't fucking know.
I don't know what people knew,
but somebody knew something and they should have fucking said something.
Um,
anyways.
All right,
asshole neighbor threatening our dogs.
Okay.
Uh,
Jesus Christ.
All right,
dear Billy butter tits.
Hey,
I'm in good shape right now.
By the way,
could you guys just insult me in a little more?
You know,
Billy,
how about Billy chiseled,
uh,
Albino Chester,
you know,
something like that.
I'm not chiseled,
whatever.
I'm a lady lady,
you wrote into my fucking podcast and I love you.
I'm a lady in my twenties,
late twenties,
here in the southeast United States,
and I have an issue with an older male neighbor.
Okay.
But brave as possible.
Why am I doing this accent,
this asshole caves common on my prop by [inaudible] and letting our dogs out of
the fence?
Oh my God.
Yeah.
I,
you need to beat this guy in the bottom of his feet.
Don't do that by the way.
I don't condone that.
Violence is never an answer.
Uh,
we live next door to a busy road and I hate to think what would happen if
someone came speeding down and hit one of my dogs.
I have a big yard,
so he has to come over into our property to open the gate.
He waits until we lead to do it.
It's easy to go down to the spy shop,
get some cameras,
because some of our neighbors snitched on him.
He's an old white trash dude that sits on his porch smoking all day.
And he claims that our dogs bark 24,
seven,
they don't,
and the rest of the neighbors have said they don't hear the barking or when they
do,
it's minimal.
All right.
This is what I would do.
I would get,
I would get a lock on my fence,
okay.
That he can't get past.
And then I would,
uh,
go down to the spy shop and get some cameras.
And then what I would also do is let them know I would write a letter and say
that that's what you've done.
Okay.
Just so,
because God forbid he jumps over the fence,
throws your dogs over,
and then they get hit and died,
you know,
then I'll die and you're going to be like,
all right,
well I caught the guy,
but what are your dogs had to die?
What you really want to do is just make,
prevent this guy from doing it.
So let them know that you know what he's doing,
that you've taken these measures and then maybe he will fuck off because you
know,
who wants to see a dog die and then an old guy go to jail or whatever,
um,
to stay on your porch revealed.
All right buddy,
get him a pair of fucking,
uh,
wireless headphones,
you know,
so we can listen to Bobbito boop,
boop,
[inaudible] Adobo but when he's fucking headphones.
Anyways,
he goes,
my question is what the hell do I,
that's what she says.
My question is,
what the hell do I do?
I've started locking the gates,
so that shouldn't be a problem anymore.
But one of this asshole tries to poison them or something and that's where the
cameras come in.
I'm probably being paranoid,
but I'm pissed off.
I also have a temper,
which doesn't help.
What do I do,
Bill?
How you're asking a guy who has a temper,
a pool immediately suggest you beat the bottom of the guy's feet.
Um,
I've heard you talk about dealing with old people,
neighbors,
and I'd really like your advice.
Thank you.
Go Fuck Yourself.
Yeah,
he's an old guy,
you know,
I would just,
I would send a letter over there and say,
I apologize if you find my dog's annoying.
Uh,
other neighbors say they don't bark that bed.
Here's a pair of fucking earplugs and some old man fucking,
I dunno what you give them,
give them some broncs or some shit.
We're now locking the fence so you can no longer go in there.
And I also have a camera set up.
Okay.
I don't want to,
you know,
I would just do that.
Whatever the fuck I said earlier,
I would do that.
And then every time you see him,
even if he tells you to go fuck yourself,
just smile and wave and just tell him,
uh,
it's nice to see you.
I hope you have a wonderful day.
I would just do that.
All right.
And then if you ever have a hard house party,
I would invite them over and just tried to kill them with kindness rather than
beating the bottom of his feet.
All right.
Dating and Asia.
Asia,
Asia.
Well this is interesting.
I never even,
I never heard about any of this dear Billy me on stains that I like that one.
Good for you.
All right.
I been living in Asia for the last four years and dating has been tricky.
Asian girls are beautiful kind and much more giving in bed than their white
counterparts.
I don't know what the fuck that means.
I'm certainly punching above my weight class here.
All right.
You Punch in these women.
Um,
I think the better thing is saying that you out kicked your coverage and having
relationships slash one night stands with a much higher quality of girl.
Uh,
then I,
when I was back in the u s three,
this is the deal.
You're over there and you have an accent.
Okay.
That said,
same way if you come over here,
if you have a fucking accident,
the women like it.
Does that work with Asian guys?
If you come over here and you have an accent with Asian women,
I have no fucking idea anyways.
However,
the biggest problem is they are boring.
Most spend their whole life studying until they are 26 then they work insane
hours at work and they live with their parents until they get married.
Not to mention that my sense of humor can be totally lost on someone who speaks
English as a second or third language.
Shamble Dude,
you're on the other side of the world.
Things are going to be different here.
I seem to be stuck between beautiful,
boring Asian girls and the typical basic white girl.
I'd apologize for this sweeping generalizations,
but you do it all the time.
Uh,
do I do it like that?
What a fucking cunt can you do?
Can you own your continuous and not fucking get yet?
You had fucking twats stench on me.
Uh,
I know I'm a fucking moron.
I don't know.
You don't point it out.
Oh boohoo I'm on the other side of the world.
Fucking a bunch of hot Asian girls.
Uh,
you got a girl that was way too good for you,
so I'd love to hear what you think.
All right.
I agree with that.
Thanks.
And Go have a wonderful day.
I live in Korea and I love it.
Didn't want to talk shit.
Um,
well dude,
you're either going to have to accept that those are your options or move out of
there.
I don't know what to tell you.
Um,
do you want the entire country to change because you're there?
Yeah.
It sounds like there's a bunch of smart women over there that they sound like
they're perfect,
right?
They're educated,
they're working their asses off the fucking there,
the bunch of animals in the rack.
Well,
what is the problem?
Um,
I dunno.
I Dunno.
I would start dating a prostitute over there if you want a little more
excitement.
Um,
sounds like you live in the dream over there,
buddy.
I,
if I was you,
I would try to appreciate what you have.
I mean,
I don't,
that's kind of perfect when she fucking blows your mind in bed and goes off and
goes studies and then you can sit down and watch the game.
Yeah.
I don't know.
I don't know exactly what else you want from a butter.
All the problems to have in the world.
Certainly after all the problems that I learned in the world in the first
fucking seven minutes of that Falcons game.
I don't,
I really don't have any fucking sympathy for you.
Alright.
Heckled by veteran comedian is fucking hilarious.
Hello,
Billy.
Bald for skin.
Um,
hey,
after about two months ago,
I don't know if they make it fun of my Dick there or what am I head looks like,
but uh,
either way.
It's funny,
about two months ago I gave the open mic night a try.
Oh,
he heckled you was an open miker that's,
that's fucking not good.
I prepared for it for awhile and finally worked up the nerve to do it.
Had material,
add some semblance,
semblance of a plan to attempt.
I get about four minutes into it and I'm getting labs.
Not a lot,
but some and a bunch of smiles.
All right,
good for you.
Plus seeing the,
even the beginning of all,
it's about,
it's just having the balls to go up there when they call your name.
It has nothing to do with how well you do anyways,
so I was confident and busted out a joke that was a little racy,
but nothing means spirited.
Knowing laughed.
Oh well I moved on.
A few days go by and I'm getting hate on Facebook for the joke from a comedian
that has been working the scene for longer than I've been alive.
Oh,
Jesus.
Really?
Yeah.
Comic con comic violence.
Ah,
yeah.
Hate to see it.
I take what he says,
his wisdom.
Benny tells me that you shouldn't ever say anything on stage.
You don't believe in,
uh,
wait a minute.
Wait.
Now wait a minute.
You're saying you're getting hate on Facebook.
This guy is basically given you advice
and being heckled.
Heckled is your,
it's interrupting a live performance.
You don't get heckled on Facebook.
Yeah.
I hate when they see the comedian heckled the crowd.
The crowd is not giving a performance.
Uh,
I,
I call bullshit on that and always thought as a comedian,
you get to push the envelope some because when it's all said and done,
as long as you weren't hateful for the sake of,
hey,
you're good anyways.
I've haven't had the nerve to go back on stage out of the fear of getting
trashed on Facebook anyways.
Love the podcast.
Hope you come to Memphis soon
and go make love to yourself.
Also.
I can't get hard.
Please fix this with magic.
Um,
all right.
Uh,
first of all,
I don't know what you said.
I'd have to know the joke that you said.
I know how you feel about the joke.
I know all the other comic feels about the joke,
but it just seems like the comic has given you advice there.
I don't know how hard the person went.
Um,
personally I wouldn't do that.
MMM.
But you sound way more seasoned than someone who just did it for the first time.
Okay.
Wait a minute.
I opened my,
I gave up my could try appeared.
I prepared for it for awhile,
Yada,
Yada.
I get my phone four minutes into it
getting laughs and then he did the joke that didn't go well.
I mean,
I don't know dude.
I don't,
I don't know.
I,
I mean,
I wouldn't say that to a,
to an open miker I also don't know what you said and it doesn't sound,
it just sounds like he's giving you a device.
Uh,
I can tell you this right now.
If you're going to let one fucking person in some bullshit on Facebook,
um,
make you not go back on stage then,
then this guy did you a favor because you gotta be weights.
You gotta be way tougher than that because if you think this is the first
fucking time,
like it's just,
you know,
when I was sitting in that motel when we were shooting the other day,
I walked in and I just laughed.
I was like,
all these places smelled the same.
Yeah.
And what are the actors asked me?
He goes,
what's the worst Gig you've ever had?
And I thought about it for a second and then I just laughed and I was just like,
that is just too big a subject
for me to pick any one gig.
I mean,
you literally have to go like,
mmm,
worst gig without a microphone.
Worst Gig in a cafeteria where they didn't know that there was a show were some
nooner.
Yeah,
worse.
Uh,
you know,
am I going to get the shit kicked out of me?
Worst Gig or I didn't get paid.
Worst gig where the fucking middle lap was a former headliner and he did 45 to
an hour in front of me and tried to burn out the crowd.
You got white crowds,
you got black crowds,
you got college crowds,
cruise ships.
I mean,
it's just,
and I,
you know what's funny is I haven't forgot any of them,
but I can't remember any of them either.
They just all are this giant ball of any,
um,
hate and humiliation
and um,
yeah,
that's what you're signing up for.
And I'm not trying to discourage you here.
And what it is,
is what you need right now rather than writing to me is you need to go to more
open mikes and what's going to happen is you're going to get comedian friends
from your graduation class,
right?
And what you do,
how you get through all of that was I used to call up,
you know
the comics that I started out with,
like I [inaudible].
I remember having some brutal show in front of a bunch of cops when he started
up any aid his ball so bad that he called me up
and through talking to me,
he was able to laugh about it and then I was laughing about it and you know,
and when I bond all the fucking time,
I would call him up.
You tell the stories.
Then what becomes is then other comics try to top your story about what the
worst gig that they ever fucking had.
And that's what it just starts to be.
Kind of as you're going through it,
you just get seasoned and then you're just all literally on stage going through
some of the worst humiliation of your life while thinking,
I can't wait to tell this to,
uh,
my buddy when I get home or whatever.
I mean,
just don't let this fucking guy discourage you.
Fucking shake it off.
Yeah.
You don't,
you gotta be like a relief pitcher.
You fucking gave up all I'm Ron,
give me another ball.
I'm going to get,
I'm gonna if I'm coming right back.
What they hate,
you gotta be like that.
Um,
I'm not saying that comic is right or wrong.
cause I don't know what you said.
He evidently felt it was serious enough to reach out to you on Facebook,
but,
uh,
I,
it's not something I would've done.
I don't try to be the comedy fucking cop here.
Um,
all right,
so good luck with you,
sir.
All right.
Just Joe Barton.
Nick says,
take your balls out of your purse and fucking get back on stage.
All right.
Good luck to you.
Caught shoplifting.
Dear bill
building the Saurus rex.
Okay.
Uh,
my wife and I have been together for 13 years and married for about half that
time.
Basically,
we are best friends with a romantic relationship.
Congratulations.
Things have recently started getting even better for us.
All of a sudden I've noticed all these extra knickknacks around the house.
Um,
I got my first job at a as a university professor and she got a job in
administration at the same university.
Oh my God.
She shoplifting.
I believe our relationship is as strong as it is because I can trust her with my
life.
I think that just changed last night after getting home from the mall,
I found her taking makeup out of her purse,
the same makeup that she refused to buy because it was too expensive.
Hurry,
action told me I wasn't supposed to see that she had it.
I confronted her about the potential shoplifting.
The conf confrontation resulted in a long argument,
one that swung from denial to anger at me crying and then back to anger.
She could never prove that she paid for it,
giving her reaction and the circumstances.
I am as confident as one could be that she shoplifted absolutely.
She would have just produced the receipt.
Yeah.
Trust me.
Don't trust is important to me.
Bill.
Um,
my wife is beautiful and she's constantly approached by men.
I need to trust that she will stay loyal to our relationship,
her shoplifting.
And then so brazenly lying to me about it puts everything into doubt for me.
How is this risk worth
her career or our relationship is shoplifting,
not that big a deal.
Could this also increase the likelihood that she is dishonest and other areas of
our relationship?
Am I crazy?
I will be listening to your advice by the way.
You killed it in Toronto.
Thank you.
Um,
ah dude.
I mean I don't know her.
I think it's all of those things.
I think it
might not be that big a deal or it could be the tip of an iceberg.
I have no idea.
But this is like the beginning of a great movie and I'm sorry that you're
starring in it.
Like,
this is like some Alfred Hitchcock Shit like rear window,
except you're in the apartment with the murderer potentially or
okay.
You know,
it just sort of ends like that war of the worlds anticlimactic.
Um,
I don't know.
But
yeah,
like do you pursue it?
Do you pursue it?
Because I'm always about like when you feel shit like that,
sit down with them and just say,
look,
I'm not saying you're a bad person.
I'm just saying how what you did make makes me feel
all right.
And then tell her everything that you just said to me.
Um,
however,
you could also be pulling some threads here and the whole thing comes crashing.
I don't fuck,
you know what do you know what I would do?
Dude?
Fuck this.
You know something.
This is what women do when they're feeling something.
They fucking,
they sit you down.
Fuck her tears,
fucker,
anger.
Fuck this.
You've got to validate what you're feeling.
You see all like,
this is what men do when they get a relationship.
He had tea.
You treat your wife,
your,
your girlfriend,
like a ticking time bomb
because they so much.
This guy's right.
I do generalize a lot on the fucking podcast on it.
They fucking,
they control the relationship with their emotions and then it's all subtly tied
to special teams,
which is your fucking,
you know,
sex life.
And if they're in a fucking bad mood about you,
you're not gonna have any fucking sex.
It's fucking ridiculous.
But that's how it works.
So,
but fuck that dude.
Like this is what you're feeling and all of that shit.
You're supposed to sit on it.
Fuck that.
What do you think your wife would do?
You don't think she would do that?
You don't think she would start snooping on your Facebook?
I don't know.
I'm not saying don't fucking snoop on the Facebook.
What I'm saying is,
is what you should do is you should tell her,
okay.
I Dunno what the what to do here.
If you fucking do a stakeout,
if you start fucking,
oh man,
that's creepy.
Okay.
Because then if you're fucking wrong,
no,
don't do that.
Cause then if you fucking wrong and she catches you spying on her,
then then she has the upper and then you become wrong because you caught her
shoplifting.
Yeah,
I would sit her down and just say,
listen,
okay,
I'm not saying you're,
you're a bad person or anything.
I'm just telling you how I feel
seeing you
shoplift and then lie to me about it and do it.
If she starts crying,
she gets angry.
Fuck that.
She's being a fucking baby and she's manipulating it and then I would also sit
there and I,
if she does that again,
I would say and now your inability.
Okay.
In a mature way to handle what it is that I'm saying to you
and the letter get his fucking angry she wants to get and it's like be like
you're getting angry at me.
I didn't steal anything.
I didn't lie about it.
Okay.
I'm just letting you know what the,
how this is making me feel and we can totally get past this.
If you're going to be an adult about this and sit down,
own up to what you did and talk me through this all,
is she going to get fucking mad at you?
And you know what?
Fuck her.
Okay.
Because this is what they'll,
this is exact fucking thing that she do to you.
And I by no means fucking,
uh,
super imposing all the fucking issues I have with women on you in your
relationship.
I absolutely am,
but that's what the fuck I would do.
And you know something.
What else do you want from me?
That's all I can do is tell you what the fuck I would do that.
That is what I would do.
All right?
It wasn't fair for her to put you in that position.
And now for you to sit there walking around carrying this fucking stress.
So I would address it with her.
All right,
there you go.
That is the podcast and hour and 20 minutes.
Jesus,
you know,
I should do these once a month.
The fucking,
the Billy red rag podcast,
you know,
once a month.
I'm just going through my cycle.
There was a lot of fucking bitch moaning and complaining on this one.
But,
uh,
I just feel like for me.
All right,
go fuck yourselves.
I'll check in on you on Thursday.
Alrighty.
That's it.
Oh,
hey,
by the way,
congratulations to the Vegas fucking Golden Knights.
You know what I mean?
He beat my Bruins last night.
I saw sue bond was in fucking net play and God damn grade,
I know.
He was in our farm system as pks brother.
I forget his first name.
Um,
it's so fucking great.
And the fans are going crazy.
It's so awesome.
Vegas is going to be a huge goddamn head and I can't wait to go to a game out
there and their colors in or about their colors,
but I actually like that logo.
I didn't notice that.
Uh,
you know,
there's a little v there when the fucking helmet.
I think that's kind of cool.
Fay Gus night helmet.
Oh,
that's clever.
All right,
let's go fuck yourself.
So I'll talk to you on Thursday.